So AI has drawn up representations that help capture both divisible levels of
obstruction structure for example. And the indivisible levels like behavior and
function. Therefore these models are sometimes called structure,
behavior, function. Let's take a simple example. All of us
are familiar with the household flashlight. You press on the button and
light comes out of the bulb. What you can see is, the button and the bulb and
the body of the flashlight. You can even open the body of the flashlight and
you might see some batteries inside your flashlight. That's all you can see.
But of course there is more going on here. To begin with,
this particular flashlight has a function. This function is invisible.
You can ascribe to it, but it's nowhere inside the body of the bulb.
One level at which it is used would analyze the flashlight is, to
ask ourselves what does it do. Not yet, how does it work? Just what does it do,
its function. Here is a representation of the function. Here is the function,
create light off that light bulb circuit, or the flashlight light bulb circuit.
There is some stimulus, some external force on the switch.
Initially there was no light, zero lumens and finally there is some light,
30 lumens. This captures the notion that when I press on the switch,
light comes out. Here is a presentation of the structure of the flashlight.
Here is a light bulb, the switch, and the battery. And they're connected.
All of them are attached. Here is the invisible causal process that we're
calling behaviour. We'll capture this behavior through a series of states and
transitions between these states. So here is electricity initially in
the battery. Then this electricity flows from the battery to the bulb, and
then the bulb converts this electricity into light. But in order for
this electricity to flow to the bulb, this particular switch has to be in
the mode ON. The switch goes into the mode ON, when someone presses on it.
Electricity is converted to light, because that's the function of the bulb.
Notice that these SBF models are nested.
We just gave an SBF model of the flashlight circuit. But now if you want, we can
do the SBF model of the lightbulb itself. How does it create light? In this way,
structure behavior function models capture not just the visible structure, but
also the invisible cause of processes, the behaviors and
the functions. Moreoever, they capture the multiple abstraction,
at the level of the flashlight, at the level of the bulb, and so on.
We'll not describe it in detail here, the structure behavior function models and
other similar models enables systems thinking in the context of diagnosis and
design of complex systems. You're provided some readings about this in
the course materials, if you want to read more about it.